the iPhone 11 Promax has a better
display than the note 10 plus in fact it
has the best smartphone display ever but
before you down vote and leave a nasty
comment let me explain exactly how and
why yesterday we put out our detailed
comparison of the iPhone 11 pro max
compared to the no 10
my two favorite phones which both have
their strings and I tried my very best
to be unbiased but I still got a ton of
hate so many people thought that I was
actually rigging the test to favor the
iPhone I absolutely wasn't and I have
proof the biggest issue people had was
the brightness comparison we're set the
brightness manually to the max and the
iPhone was so much brighter and I knew
the apples really stuffed out their
display game with the iPhone 11 pros but
I thought that they had just kind of
stepped up and finally reached the level
of the note ends and the zest and
plusses displays that's why I was so
shocked to see how much brighter was
just as shocked as you guys were and so
I spent about 5 minutes going through
every single setting to make sure that
there wasn't any power modes or any
other software limiting the brightness
and there wasn't it was actually set to
+10 percent brightness in the settings
and in the high performance mode but
we're still seeing a huge difference so
after seeing all of the comments that we
decided to investigate further and see
what was causing this we started to read
to our testing and made sure that the
note was charged and once again the
power settings were set to full
performance I turned off the auto
brightness and set both to the max and
right there right away I saw the same
exact results as we did before now I
have to mention that cameras are more
sensitive to light differences but even
in person the difference is very big as
I was testing I turned off the display
of the note 10 and turned it back on and
right then my eyes caught something the
note 10 started off being fairly bright
and then almost instantly it dimmed the
display even though is manually set to
the max whereas the iPhone stayed
consistent this had me thinking what if
the note 10 can't run anywhere near the
full brightness if there's a lot of
bright content on the display to test
this I found a wallpaper designed for
all it displays that is mostly black as
you can see the iPhone is still brighter
but the results are much much closer
than before
next I opened up YouTube when the
thanks page we're dark mode is enabled
and then now they are actually closer
but iPhone is still a little bit
brighter and to test this further I
decided to play back a Netflix HDR video
and interestingly when the video is
paused the white controls are actually
slightly brighter on the note 10 but as
soon as we start playing back content
and there's more bright areas the iPhone
has a sizable lead I've previously heard
that it's best to keep your phone and
auto brightness as many phones can
actually get brighter that way if you're
in direct sunlight so we had it outside
and I opened up the verge which has a
dark design and I scrolled to fill most
of the display with black so with auto
brightness on and this method where the
Sun is just banging on the screen the
note 10 was actually very slightly
brighter than the iPhone so we have our
answer the note n+ does have a display
that is capable of the same 1200 nits as
the iPhone but the times that it can
actually get that high and sustain it
there is quite rare so that means we
have either hardware or software
limitations or probably both that don't
allow it to reach the same sustain
levels as the iPhone now some of you
will say how could this be if Samsung
makes these displays for Apple while
Samsung does make the displace but just
the panels themselves not the display
controller not the calibration not the
software and other things that set it
apart if you just look at the spec sheet
they seem very similar or practically
the same but in the real world there are
some clear differences now brightness
isn't the only thing that matters we
also have things like color accuracy
reflections contrast etc and this is
where display mates crazy detailed tests
come in they rated the iPhone 11 pros
display as the highest absolute color
accuracy smaller shift in color highest
full screen brightness 408 phones and
highest peak HDR brightness and along
with that the lowest screen reflections
and the smallest brightness shift taking
a deep dive into their results I once
again found validation for a first
comparison they say that the note 10
produces 410 nets when maxing out the
brightness and manual on a white screen
compared to the iPhones 770 bits and for
a more normal average use case of 50%
the note tent has 465 Nets compete
to 821 that is a huge difference and
that is exactly what we saw in our
comparison so there we have it proof
that the iPhone 11 Pro does in fact have
the better display that it gets
noticeably brighter with average use and
that original comparison wasn't biased
or set up in any way we were just as
shocked as you guys were and now we know
exactly why I also want to add in that
the note 10 plus still has a display
that is gorgeous with super thin bezels
without a notch and the brightness and
colors are better than almost every
single phone that is out there and if
you buy one of these you will definitely
not be disappointed but our original
comparison and test do stand true so
thank you guys for watching if you guys
want to see that original comparison if
you guys didn't see it click right over
there click a Bob to subscribe and down
below to enable notifications listen max
with Max tech and I will see you in the
next one